All right, to introduce this concept,
it's going to help to have another definition that I haven't given you yet.
So here's a graph, we have been talking about things like shortest paths.
So let's look at a path from a to g. So here's a natural path to choose.
It's one of the shortest paths from a to g, but it's by no means the only path from a to g.
So here's another path from a to g. a to b to e to d to a to b to e to g. It's a path.
It's going from node to node crossing edges but it's not a simple path.
So simple path is not allowed to have any repeated nodes.
Any shortest path is going to be a simple path. Right. Why?
Because if we had any repeats along the way from a to g,
if we visit b and then sometime later we go back to b then there's going to be a path
that just goes from a to b and then using this path from b to g.
We don't need any of these links in between.
So if the shortest path actually had on it a repeat, it was not simple path,
then it can't be a shortest path, there must be a shorter path still, so that's a contradiction.
Now the longest simple path that you can have, can have it most
n nodes on it because there is only n nodes in the graph and we're not allowed to repeat any.
So the longest simple path is at link n. This graph has seven nodes.
So let's ask the question having to do with this graph here.
I want you to check each box with number K next to it
if there's a simple path of K nodes that goes from a to g.
So for example, it can't be one beacause it has to have at least a and g on it,
and we already solved path a, b, e, g
that's a simple path that has four nodes on it, so I'll give you four.
For each possible length, check the box if there is a simple path
with that number of nodes on it from a to g.